RULES COMMITTEE FOR TWENTY APRIL
NINETEEN.
CLEARLY HEREBY COLD ORDER
PLEASE REVISE AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS.
HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED. OF
MADAME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO.
TORONTO HERE FRIEDMAN HERE
HERE THOSE AREA PRESENT
CALENDAR YEAR GRAYSON. MANAGED
SO LESS WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA.
AND.
ITEM FIVE ON OUR REGULAR AGENDA
TODAY.
THERE'S A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. TAKEN MOVED AND SECONDED
MOVE ON THIS CAREER SECOND.
MS FRIEDMAN.
.
BAD SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY.
AYE COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO AYE CARILLO ICE. AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GALLAGHER AYE
CALENDAR AYE GRAYSON AYE
SREESANTH AYE.
MAYES I KNOW THERE AND. NAZARIAN
AYE SOLIS WALDRON.
OKAY THAT MOTION PASSES.
WE NOW MOVE TO OUR REGULAR
AGENDA.
SLIDING OVER FRIEDMAN.
IF YOU'LL PROCEED THREE YEARS
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION AMERICAN
INDIANS WERE LOST HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF A SERIOUS GREETS
AND OTHER CHRISTIANS PERSON ONE
OF THE MOST ATROCIOUS
VIOLATIONS.
IN HUMAN RIGHTS HISTORY. HR
THIRTY SEVEN COMMEMORATES THE
HUNDRED THIRD THIRD ANNIVERSARY
OF THE START OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. THE RESOLUTION CALLS
UPON US TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE LIVES
LOST DURING A DARK CHAPTER OF
OUR SHARED HISTORY. THE
CHALLENGES ARE LEADERS ACROSS
THE GLOBE TO PUSH BACK TO GET
SUGGESTIONS ADDED TOLERANCE WAS
KILLED A BETTER MORE PEACEFUL
WORLD. AT CELEBRATE THE TRIUMPH
OF THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE OVER
ADVERSITY I'M HUMBLED TO
REPRESENT THE LARGEST POPULATION
OF ARMENIANS IN THE U. S. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
FOR A GOOD.
ANY WITNESSES SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
IS OUR MOTION ON THIS ITEM SOME
OF THEIR.
YEAH MOVE OVER SIR MAYES SECOND
IF I MISSED WAS AREA PASS AND
THE SCHOOL'S CRAZY
DRUNK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.